and garrett cole will take the mound
tonight for the new york yankees and he
is coming off of his first
loss since may the 22nd of 2019 coming
at the hands
of the atlanta braves arrows arena is
ready
strike three alright zarina is down on
strikes
gandhi diaz takes second base now gmon
choi
who has two career home runs in the
regular season against cole
and strokes this one back into right all
the way back is frazier
and this one is gone home run for joy
here
in the first inning to give the raise a
two-nothing lead
his third home run and he continues to
fare extremely well
in his matchups against cole class now
taking them out tonight for the race
seventh start of the season
two out and no one on and two nothing
raised leaves it for mike ford
swinging a line drive into right field
hanging in the air and caught by
brandon loud that ball was hit hard but
directly at the race right fielder
and with the bases empty up comes kevin
kiermeier
there's a shot well tagged into right
and that baby's gonna get out of here
into the second deck keermeyer pulls one
out
and the rays have a three-nothing lead
so now cole
is tied with stripling for the most home
runs in the major leagues allowed for
12. now two down here is manuel margot
and he hits a drive to deep center back
goes gardner a way back
makes the catch a step or two from the
warning track right in front of the
monument block wall
meyer on second rosarina is on first two
men out top of the fourth three-nothing
race
get hard on the ground but the second
base lame flips the first
and the inning is over no runs no heads
two left
think he's still looking for their first
hit that one base runner or walk by
gardner with two outs in the third no
two down
and here's clint frazier he fly to
center his first time
breaking ball and down goes frazier down
goes frasier he tried to hold up and he
could not stick strikeout
of the ball game for tyler glass now
he's been really good
here's a chance for manuel margot joy at
third adamus at second and wendell at
first we're going to line drive up the
middle basin
indus score is choy adams to third being
held
the throwback to second and wendell's in
a rundown
lemay who runs over and tags him out but
margot scampers up to second base
the rays have a four nothing lead a
tyler glasnow threw four innings
no runs no hits six strikeouts
one walk the walk obviously tomorrow's
a perfect game he got the no hitter
going as we hit the fifth
so the yankees have a base runner and
scoring position without the benefit of
a hit
roll back to the mountain glasnell's got
it heads out of first lobster that way
and he's got five no hit innings in the
bronx tonight rosarina
able to pick up his first stolen base
gets himself in a sworn position the
swing at a line drive sinking into
center charging corner at lance for a
base hit
a rosarina around third and he scores
easily and gmon joy is having a night
and the rays have a five-nothing lead in
the bronze here we go to the bottom of
the six brett gardner leads off
the ground right side diving stop loud
throw to first got him
and that's some play by brandon lau he
just saved the no hit
bid going by glass now by diving out
into right field
absolutely took a hit away from brett
gardner and here is lemayo
slow ground ball into the hole left side
adamus has it over the top throw the
furs
the stretch by troy out at first base a
very close
play they're gonna take a look dj's foot
hits it in the back
the ball is still not quite in the
webbing i believe
and it is overturned so lemayo is safe
and the yankees will not be no hit
giorshala over two today
well here comes the payoff to urshela
swung on and hit in the air to right
field in deep
back goes renfro she's gone
over the leap of renfro into the right
field seats so
geo oshella greets garcia with a home
run tonight
geoachella the most happy fella
no he's the most happy bella
though he homers and the yankees now
trail 5-1
so the yankees have a good start to
their
eighth inning they trail by four voigt
is over three
drill to left field fairball it's gone
it is
gone a home run for voight a two-run
shot and the yankees are now back in and
it's 5-3
point hits one to detroit a
two-run blast oh that void is a droid
and the yankees now trail 5-3 hicks is
the base runner at first lemay who
is the tying run as he stands in chopper
back towards the mount castillo's got it
turns
goes to first but rays have defeated the
yankees they have beaten them again at
yankee stadium they go to 4-0 in the
bronx this year